Every Porsche has the soul of a sports car,...
...but everyone talks about this one;...
...does its best work here, here and over there.
The 911.
Perfected since 1963.
Engine in the back, driver up front.
Launches like one of these, turns like one of these.
That profile, find me a more timeless shape.
Go look, I'll wait.
The 911 is the spirit of Porsche.
More than a million made.
Rear wheel drive, all-wheel drive, take your pick.
Two seats, four seats, wings, scoops and flex, you name it.
And then there's this.
The 718 Cayman and Boxster, roof or no roof.
Trunk in the front, engine in the middle...
...and actually, another trunk in the back.
Like those tail lights?
Memorize them because that's all you'll see.
Like their big brother, they're lightweight and fun and inspired by racing.
Does that make them perfect? I think so.